okay so this is Devi
there's no good life in it I found maybe
they were going there robbed but at you
there is a real Devi the voice actors
name is actually what Davey Johnson with
that yeah Davey Johnson is Davey Johnson
it's like the most stereotypically
American name - is it just like Davey
Johnson like John Smith is ants like
just and he just sounds like the it's a
good choice I know that's someone that
just works on the staff or what but I
mean it's like just sounds like the
everyday average guy so what happens it
this is great big a lot play stuff
happens in that first couple seconds I
love this this giant creature just
flying over dragon is flying over
everybody runs away Jake just while
playing a game just watch a spin in the
air not even looking up Finn the whole
time it's just making this oh well he's
going and getting flung back a dude
twirls these what's the guy down the
middle again oh I always hear all this
crap that shows like cartoon shows are
called on this how is it getting away
with this stuff I mean it's awesome
no blood i I guess so and he still seems
to be alive a little people are coming
out Kayne but it's like it's so weird
they don't get paranoid agree about that
maybe they're just like oh hey my kids
smart I give them credit to not be
pussies um so you're right they can't be
a bad date just don't watch what they
watch so yeah so he saves all these
people inside this drag and they all
become super up says to become as
fanboys this is one upside-down ice
cream cone guy that's especially funny
really really funny so v decides to
create an alternate or a different
identity shaves his hair which is really
sad BMO's incredibly cute yeah be by
execute then he shaves his hair and gets
those fake mustaches how do I look okay
maybe laughs hard um and he just walks
outside just being a normal guy like
he's not being a hero or anything just
going through sitting on benches and
fine and I gotta get a job yeah I gotta
get a job um hang up rooms
yes sweeping up brooms and he liked it
so much he starts to think he really is
Davey and he's just doing everyday
boring stuff you know or just feeling
himself out how is getting a job you
know stuff like that and Jake tries to
convince him that he really is Finn he
goes through this whole personality
disorder I guess and finally comes
around to be Finn but he's gonna be
taking it once more to get Jake at jail
because he gets himself in trouble they
put the Robert disguise in a mustache
and of course that wolf Picard's into
thinking it's two people but people are
chasing and they put Jake in the pocket
which still has the lines on it and I
remember that and he farts again the end
so no it was definitely a it was
definitely a fun episode um like nothing
with the exception of the opening
nothing super weird I mean nothing
compared the other ones yeah I mean
we've seen weirder yeah eating the
chocolate okay you were like what um but
the the mustache talking that really
made me laugh we puts it you know it's
one thing cuz he's talking with himself
and then we put some the whores it's
like you know by baby my friend that was
really funny um so no it was definitely
really funny and I think you know people
I've seen people just like not on things
about like celebrity I'm just gonna
people that go through really extreme
stuff for a while and just long for
something really quiet and really
mundane again so I'm like I really like
when he's just sitting on the porch with
a guy you kind of know is he's just
getting to know them and they're just
whatever having lemonade yeah Randy
that's right and it's just kind of
chewing and it's the only thing that
comes to mind is after on his way back
when james rolfe just got done shooting
his last day of his movie and he was
coming through he's coming through
Chicago we shot a cameo with him and
I just said how'd it go it's just like
oh man he's like you know it's the
hardest thing I ever did and you know
the man it was so crazy and stuff and
he's like I just sort of longed for
sitting on the porch and hearing birds
again you know like is it's just so
distant from what he's been doing for
like the past however long that took
like you know for probably half a year
or something so I think there is
something it's not even necessary being
a celebrity I think it's just doing
something being a state of mind that's
so different or so strange that you just
take for granted the simple stuff again
so I thought was fun I you know not
great but I thought it was fine you um I
loved beemo just running around just the
colors the emo he is freaking like every
time I think people can't get work
adorned Oh like does something out just
like your hands like oh no oh don't
disguise like that was just cute um I
loved how when Finn was shaving his head
there's BMO crying and then has the X's
four eyes yeah when Finn comes
downstairs and Jake's like oh my god
intruder he's like oh no no he's like oh
do you think it's gonna work and Finn
just goes I can't stand up cuz it'll be
C here's finger just goes yeah decide
what's up the window underneath and he's
like that was awesome do they ever I
mean you've seen a head I mean do they
ever explain the auto-tune poison Holden
did doing why he can do that remember
that a little computer I swallowed all
that wait do we ever see him swallow
that comfy no that was before they never
show it happened but when he was what
was that Bree my daughter's over there
going what wait I met the jiggler yeah
baby
I know he says hey Jake goes how do you
do that
remember the computer I swallowed a
little while ago yeah hmm
but they never actually show no I never
right okay I love him he's like talking
to Randy he's like yeah so we're going
to put them over here and make it look
more cabin like we'll make a left side
and a front side how about a roof I
don't know maybe I don't know um when
the guard comes down and he's carrying
the plate of food
here's your prison food we feed our
prisoners here or the guard hey the
guards going like this nice sweep your
body yeah I'm feeling a little dirty you
know how to party I mean it was I don't
want to say like nothing happened
but it was a very I think kind of like
the premise of the episode was Fitness
wants to be basic wants to be normal
they kind of toned everything down to go
along with that I think a lot of the
bizarreness kind of disappeared because
in the beginning it was very whoa whoa
yeah very big very over-the-top and then
once you became DV kind of like all
settled down and settled down which i
think was kind of the intent oh yeah
that was fun yeah I mean it's I'm Sur
with you there's now like an episode
where it's I mean we've seen episodes
that are more subdued but are like super
only smokes that's funnier yeah yeah or
something and there's once where it's
like blah those really subdued but that
that's Ogden nothing happened yeah this
one's got like a in between like you
know it's it had some really really good
jokes it was just creative enough and
just enough of you know sort of an
addition to Finn's character that you
can identify with no I can't
I you can get in his position and no
you're right you never will no but I can
and that's what matters I was gonna be
speaking up how many fans do you have
coming up to you being like not not to
that level obviously they're blowing out
of proportion or are they or summer
summer no really I'm not I mean not many
but I mean it's like there are a lot of
times where you have to sort of be like
I mean like just a random fan will come
up and be like you know yeah hey can I
just you know got a dinner with you or
something like that and it's just like
I don't know you guys you know I mean I
give you kudos for a brilliant template
I don't know you um so but most of that
it's almost always at a con I mean like
in real life I mean it's just like oh
you dog walker okay cool I mean that's
about it I mean it doesn't go any
crazier past that oh oh it happens to me
all the time
oh it's super famous you might get
recognized at cons and stuff like that
No
yeah what my wife did that's the PB
hater no that's gonna happen to go to
the next con because of that oh no
that's that's a no that's always like
the build-up like oh my god it's gonna
be crazy the all habeas like you know
but then we'd be in real life it's like
oh hi ho how are you oh my god just like
key sign this is like it's all the feet
act out to say what you think but ya
know just uh just a fun episode die got
nothing else
exactly okay no segue for you no no
there's no need for one the next one is
gonna yeah well uh let's see pie lemon
machinery ice their cat just died that's
what that was no no it's just sleeping
way to run that joke